dans la cohésion
géraldine maillet en faire une très
belle bouteille à benjamin castaldi lors
son anniversaire elle intervient il lui
a dit qu'il s'était régalé alors qu'en
réalité ne l'a jamais vu car elle traîne
encore en loge depuis six mois
une chroniqueuse meurtri chat le
dimanche 28 mars 2021 c'est
l'anniversaire de benjamin cas ce que
j'ai il n'y a pas de tpm dès ce jour là
donc dès le lundi j'arrive avec un
paquet cadeau et avec une bouteille
magnifique de prosecco je lui offre il
est ravi il me remercie et le lendemain
il dit je me suis régalé je les vis avec
ma femme merci bon hier je vais dans les
loges je cherche une veste j'ouvre le
casier de benjamin castaldi et je
découvre le paquet cadeau non à la dive
bouteille
alors c'est vrai
c'est vrai mais ça me rappelle un
certain cyril lma
c'était dans la sauce
celui-là il faut mettre dans la sauce il
est vous soumettre l' écouteront avec un
cast a dit nuls c'est horrible ce que tu
as fais moi
prosecco c'est un vin à cette heure où
et c'est l'argent qui compte